NCIS has been a staple of the CBS
primetime lineup for a stunning 20
seasons and Counting that's a very long
time for a TV show to run and over that
time several regulars and guest stars
have sadly passed on
NCIS guest star Annie worshing died from
cancer in January 2023 at the age of
just 45 though she was better known for
her roles on the show's 24 The Vampire
Diaries in Bosch as well as playing
tests in the acclaimed video game The
Last of Us where Shing appeared as
Deputy D.A Gail Walsh in the NCIS season
8 episode false witness deadline
reported that wershing was diagnosed
with cancer in 2020 but she didn't let
that keep her from the career she loved
and she continued working as long as she
was able in 2022 she played the board
Queen in season 2 of Star Trek Picard
and she continued with her recurring
role as Rosalind Dyer on the rookie
until 2022. her Picard role brought her
career full circle her earliest screen
credit was on Star Trek Enterprise in
2002. actor Abigail Spencer who worked
with washing on the show Timeless shared
a heartfelt tribute to worshiping on
Instagram calling her the best scene
partner Spencer added that rorsching was
the backbone and the ringer on many
shows she graced one of the true marks
of a great character actor is the
ability to play multiple different roles
within the same universe of shows this
is something that Gregory gets into
several times throughout his long acting
career perhaps most notably on Star Trek
it's in played five different characters
across Deep Space Nine Voyager and
Enterprise he also played multiple roles
on Empty Nest Night Court the practice
and of course NCIS on NCIS and its
related shows it's in played three
different characters under Secretary of
State Lawrence Culbertson and Jag
director Charlie and a pair of season
one episodes of NCIS and Spencer Downing
in a season 17 episode of NCIS which
turned out to be his final role the
Downing family business isn't exactly
what it used to be it'sin's most
prominent and celebrated role was
President Charles Logan on 24 a
character he played for three seasons he
received two Emmy nominations for his
performance itson died in 2022 after
emergency surgery led to complications
his family confirmed to deadline he was
74. director and producer John kasar who
worked with it's in on 24 wrote in a
tribute tweet he'll be missed by his 24
family who had nothing but love and
respect for him he made your mark now
rest in peace friend even if you you've
never watched a single episode of Deep
Space Nine you might have heard of a
character Odo the shapeshifter who was
played by Renea version for all seven
seasons a virgin wall was best known for
that role but there was a lot more to
him than Star Trek it was also a series
regular on both Benson and Boston Legal
and he appeared in films including the
original Mash in which he played Father
John Mulcahy abarjanwa's life off screen
was just as interesting as his life on
it the New York native was named after
his grandfather a renowned
post-impressionist painter from
Switzerland his father was a swiss-born
journalist and his mother was a member
of the French aristocracy a relative of
one of Napoleon bonaparte's Marshals he
spent time in Paris and London during
his childhood and briefly lived in an
artist Colony he always seemed destined
for a career in the Arts and excelled as
an actor both on camera and on stage he
won a Tony Award for his turn in the
musical cuckoo in 1970 and was also
nominated for two Emmys one for Benson
and one for the practice his one guest
appearance on NCIS came in season 10 as
Dr Felix Blackwell a virgin while died
from cancer in 2019 at the age of 79.
television veteran Ralph Waite had been
gracing the small screen for a long time
prior to his eight episode stint on NCIS
he delivered an emmy-nominated
performance in Roots but he was best
known for portraying patriarch John
Walton senior on the long-running
historical drama of The Waltons a role
he played on all nine seasons of the
original series as well as six
subsequent TV movies but it also
appeared in such classic films as Five
Easy Pieces and Cool Hand Luke on NCIS
he played the role of Jackson Gibbs
father to seriously Leroy Jethro Gibbs
rape portrayed the character right up
until the end of his life Jackson Gibbs
died in the season 11 episode honor thy
father which aired three months after
Wade's death in February 2014 at the age
of 85. I'm still your father
yes you are we had also dabbled in
politics he ran for congress in
California three times losing in a
primary race in 1990 and in both a
special and general election in 1998.
aside from a role that was largely cut
out of 2001's Legally Blonde actor
Cheney clay applied his trade in TV for
the bulk of his career his lengthiest
gig was as a recurring character officer
Asher on the shield appearing on 16
episodes of the award-winning FX police
drama with some airing after his 2007
death Asher was notable for being one of
the only characters on the show that it
seemingly earned the trust of Vic Mackey
clay seemed to be carving out a niche on
cop shows also Landing guest star roles
on CSI Cold Case and as an FBI agent on
Las Vegas he popped up early in the Run
of NCIS playing Corporal Paul Brinkman
in the show's second episode clay
tragically passed away in July 2007 in
just 34. a result of complications from
sleep apnea according to his memorial
page his final completed role was in the
movie one way to Valhalla released two
years after his death Charles Durning
appeared in numerous critically
acclaimed films Dog Day Afternoon The
Sting Tootsie O Brother Where out thou
and the Muppet movie to name but a few
the late actor was a two-time Oscar
nominee for his roles and to be or not
to be and The Best Little Whorehouse in
Texas and a Tony winner for his
performance as big daddy in the 1990
Broadway run of count on a Hot Tin Roof
learning also did plenty of Television
over the years it was a series regular
on the sitcom Evening Shade for which he
won an Emmy and a recurring character on
Rescue Me for which he was nominated for
an Emmy he had further Emmy nominations
for the 1976 television miniseries
captains and the Kings the series
homicide life on the streets and NCIS
where he was recognized for his
performance as Ernie Yost in the
acclaimed 2004 episode call of Silence
during once told USA Today that he was
born a character actor adding I was born
looking older and I've been aging since
I was a teenager he passed away from
natural causes in 2012 at the age of 89
leaving behind not only a stellar body
of acting work but a highly decorated
military career according to the US Army
website he was a surviv of the June 6
D-Day invasion who received a silver
star and three purple hearts you get
wounded iguana canal and then they sent
you to Iwo I'm not an army but a lot of
Marines yeah
shows like NCIS are often a great
showcase for aging actors I guess spot
doesn't require a significant time
commitment but the roles are usually
more meaty than a quick appearance on a
sitcom or soap opera NCIS in particular
seems to do a great job at casting
longtime Veterans of the business and
helping them get one last great role
before they retire or pass away Nina
fodge got that chance when she played
Victoria Mallard in two episodes of NCIS
one in season two and again in season
three as a mother of Donald Ducky
Mallard Bunch got to play an important
character in the show's Canon it was one
of her last ever appearances helping to
cap a career that stretched all the way
back to the 1940s her notable credits
include iconic films such as the Ten
Commandments and An American in Paris
and classic television shows including
Gunsmoke Bonanza and Murder She Wrote
The New York Times reported that plotch
died in 2008 at the age of 84 calling
her an actress in sophisticated roles
character actor Terry Rhodes wasn't
particularly well known though he was
beloved in Denver the Arts blog culture
West noted his impact on Colorado
theater was enduring Rhodes play the
leading man at dozens of Country Dinner
Playhouse shows the closest he came to
making it big in Hollywood was as a main
cast member in the fox sitcom living in
captivity which was canceled before the
end of its first season he started as
Gordon the security guard of a gated
community where the show was set after
that many of his characters were
nameless defined purely by their
professions but he managed what many
other character actors struggled to
achieve he landed regular work on NCIS
Rhodes appeared as Captain and Dr Brent
Peters in a season one episode casting
directors often saw him as a medical
professional he also played doctors on
That 70s Show Bones My Wife and Kids Two
and a Half Men and the list goes on
moviegoers may remember roads from liar
liar in which he played a pilot he died
in October 2013 at the age of 61
according to culture West one of the
first actors you see in the very first
episode of NCIS is Jerry Becker who is
escorting the show's version of
President George W bush through an
airplane not many people can say they
got to help introduce a show to millions
of viewers that would be on the air for
20 years but Becker is one of them the
actor's First Love was theater and
that's where he did the bulk of his work
particularly in the Chicago area
throughout the 1980s and 90s his most
notable stage credit came in 1993 when
he appeared in the Broadway play the
song of Jacob Zulu playing the character
Marty Frankel Becker played plenty of
film and TV characters during his career
including sizable roles in the movies
Donnie Brosco man on the moon Mickey
Blue Eyes in 2002 Spider-Man in
Spider-Man he played a member of the
Oscorp board of directors who clashed
with Norman Osborne Over plants to sell
the company he gets killed by Osborne
after he becomes a Green Goblin Becker
stepped away from acting in the 2010s
with his last credited screen role being
a 2008 episode of Law and Order he
passed away in April 2019 due to
complications related to diabetes
according to Chicago Theater bike ride
another actor who played separate
characters on JAG and NCIS is Bruce gray
he first appeared on JAG in a 2002
episode as Brigadier General Sawyer and
later made the jump to NCIS in 2004 as
assistant director Jonathan Overmeyer in
the season one episode these are just
two of the many guest appearances gray
made in the 2000 thousands in 2010s
including roles on How I Met Your Mother
The West Wing and Boston Legal among
many others Ray also played vice admiral
chicoti a senior Starfleet officer in
Star Trek the Next Generation and Star
Trek Deep Space Nine born in Puerto Rico
to Canadian parents gray lived in San
Juan until he was a teenager he cut his
teeth on the stage heading to England to
tread the boards of London's mermaid
theater opposite Donald Sutherland in
androglis and the lion he then returned
to North America and spent the early
part of his acting career in Canada
before eventually settling in Los
Angeles where he resided at the time of
his death at age 81 in October 2017.
producer Allison Richards told The
Hollywood Reporter Bruce was not only an
amazingly talented actor but an
incredible role model on set he Charmed
the entire cast and crew of don't talk
to Irene with his warmth generosity and
incredible wit other notable movie roles
of his include Starship Troopers Water
for Elephants and My Big Fat Greek
Wedding one of the biggest losses to the
NCIS family was Miguel Ferrer who died
from throat cancer in 2017 at the age of
61. Ferrera played Owen Granger on NCIS
Los Angeles starting as a recurring
character in season 3 and season 4
before becoming a main cast member for
season 5 through season 8. it wouldn't
be the first or only series Ferrera was
a regular player on as he graced the
cast of many television shows during his
40-plus year career though it wouldn't
air until after his death Ferrera
reprized the role of FBI agent Albert
Rosenfield for the Revival of Twin Peaks
after having previously played the
character in The Original Series in the
follow-up film firewalk with me I reject
absolutely Revenge aggression and
retaliation
the foundation of such a method is love
he was also a main cast member in
Crossing Jordan and he had multi-episode
stents on the protector in 2007's Bionic
Woman his big screen breakthrough was in
the original RoboCop and he went on to
appear in films like Star Trek 3 traffic
and Iron Man 3. he played vice president
Rodriguez in the Marvel movie a corrupt
character who was impeached for his role
in the Mandarin's Terror attacks rare
also did a lot of Voice work he brought
us distinctive tones to everything from
Disney's Mulan to shows like Jackie Chan
Adventures Adventure Time and Young
Justice he was the first cousin of
George Clooney who told variety that
Ferreira made the world brighter and
funnier in a statement following his
death stage and Screen veteran Barbara
tarbuck made the rounds in the soap
opera circuit during her long career she
had multi-episode stance on Dynasty
Falcon Crest and Santa Barbara before
taking a recurring role in general
hospital that lasted for over 40
episodes her most recent extended stint
on a series was the asylum season of
American Horror Story playing mother's
Superior Claudia in what would be one of
her final screen roles between her so
proper days and her final years tarbuck
racked up an impressive resume of TV
show appearance included the likes of er
NYPD Blue six-speed under and more as
well as the season 1 NCIS episode she
didn't do many movies but her film roles
included short circuit Curly Sue and the
2004 remake of Walking Tall according to
the Hollywood Reporter tarbuck did a lot
of regional theater work and was an
acting teacher at UCLA the Detroit
native passed away in December 2016 from
the degenerative brain disorder
krutzfelt Jacob disease she was 74.
after playing Dr Donald Ducky Mallard on
461 episodes of NCIS actor David
McCallum died of natural causes on
September 25th 2023 six days after his
90th birthday the last remaining
original member of the NCIS cast
following Mark Hammond's 2019 departure
mccallum's absence in the upcoming 21st
season will be felt by all and signify
the end of an era McCallum was a
familiar face long before he warmed the
hearts of viewers as ducky initially
made an impact with small parts in the
classic films a night to remember and
the Great Escape for decades he was
remembered as Russian secret agent Ilya
kriyakin on the man from Uncle for 104
episodes McCallum also starred in the
British drama colditz in the
Supernatural series Sapphire and steel
he later developed a pension for Lending
his vocal talents to cartoons voicing
Professor Paradox in the Ben 10
franchise and Alfred pennyworth in three
separate direct-to-video Batman features
over his 90 years McCallum narrated
documentaries wrote a mystery novel and
even released four separate Studio
albums with Capitol Records which showed
off his musical abilities by playing a
host of instruments McCallum is survived
by his wife four children and eight
grandchildren Los Angeles native Michael
Gilden who died by Suicide at age 44 in
2006 had a fascinating career that began
with an appearance in the 1981 Chevy
Chase comedy under the rainbow he was
one of several little person actors to
appear in the film all playing actors
from 1939's Wizard of Oz Carrie Fisher
was also in that film and Gildan would
reunite with her a few years later when
he was hired to play one of the Ewoks in
Return of the Jedi he went on to do both
acting and stunt work in several notable
films including Pulp Fiction Last Action
Hero and my giant idiots also had a very
television career appearing in The
Amanda Show family law Charmed and CSI
in addition to his two episodes in the
fourth season of NCIS where he played
Marty Pearson Gildan also worked as a
stockbroker and was involved in
organizations that supported Little
People his wife at the time of his death
actor Meredith Eaton made history when
she joined the cast of Family Law
becoming the first woman with dwarfism
to ever be a regular on a prime time
television series
Sam sarpong accomplished a lot in his
life despite it being cut tragically
short the london-born multi-hyphenate
was an actor model television host
singer writer producer and director he
was one of the earliest guest stars on
NCIS appearing in the third ever episode
he began his acting career almost a
decade earlier when he snagged an
uncredited role in my so-called life he
steadily built up a respectable TV
resume in the years that followed
popping up in the likes of er Everybody
Hates Chris 24 and Bones his final
appearance was a posthumous one An
American Crime Story sarpong moved to
Los Angeles to live with his father at
age 11. he played basketball in high
school and according to the independent
he wanted to play professionally but he
turned to modeling and acting when that
didn't work out it became a well-known
television presenter co-hosting MTV's yo
mama and later fronting the pre-show of
the annual BET Awards he showed off his
musical skills on screen in projects
like Carmen and hip-hopra and off-screen
as music supervisor on several films it
was also a successful recording artist
in his own right with his group The
League having sold over a million
records worldwide surprise jumped off a
California bridge to his death on
October 2015. he was 40. his sister TV
presenter June subprong said in a
statement his passing is a loss for the
world I'd ask anyone who's going through
tough times to seek help please talk to
someone if you or anyone you know is
having suicidal thoughts please call the
National Suicide Prevention Lifeline at
1-800-273-talk 8255
foreign